if they're going to drop a hammer on you
and prosecute you to the full extent of
them do my time in jail
do you remember
the last time you saw JonBenet alive did
you murder your sister JonBenet
Shelly yes Phil you're still beautiful
I'm not this is
a beautiful person and that's a wrap on
Dr Phil after 21 Seasons the TV Doc's
long-running daytime talk show is coming
to an end that's it on Tuesday Dr Phil
announced the news in a statement
revealing that he's decided to end
production after the current season
wraps up later this year I have been
blessed with over 25 wonderful years in
daytime television with this show we
have helped thousands of guests add
millions of viewers through everything
from addiction and marriage to mental
wellness and raising children we really
tune in to our viewers we let them
decide what we're going to talk about
when we wrap our season I give everybody
a couple of weeks to chill and then we
start working on Reinventing ourselves
for the next year how can we tell our
stories better
how can we connect with the viewers more
how can we dial in Dr Phil adds that the
show has been an incredible chapter of
his life and career but there is so much
more he hopes to do I couldn't be more
excited according to the clinical
psychologist that includes Prime Time
programming Endeavors and he'll be
announcing a strategic Prime Time
partnership soon it is not easy I mean
doing your own show
even my own mother asked me one time she
said Phil what do you do the other 23
hours a day
you know like it's just bang you're
there and gone but it's a lot of work
quote I am compelled to engage with a
broader audience because I have grave
concerns for the American family and I
am determined to help restore a Clarity
of purpose as well as our core values
I get to talk to interesting people
about interesting things and I'm doing
it in a very different way before
launching his show in 2002 Dr Phil
appeared on the Oprah Winfrey Show for
several years starting in the late 90s I
never in was inspired to have my own
show that was never in my view or even
to be on television it just kind of
happened organically so when it was time
Oprah said let me get you remember a
couple of things number one don't let
them change who you are be authentic be
who you are and I really took that to
heart
and secondly she said lighting is
everything
CBS Media Ventures the company that
distributes Dr Phil has announced plans
to offer stations Library episodes for
the
2023-2024 season and Beyond and will
include new content like intros from Dr
Phil and guest updates
as for Dr Phil himself one thing's for
sure he's grateful for the time he spent
on your TV I've been very blessed I
think 20 years who gets to do that and I
really look at it uh with great humility
that people have trusted me enough to
allow me into their homes and to be part
of their lives for 20 years
[Music]